pour les habitants de mayotte c'était
aujourd'hui la deuxième phase de leur
choix après avoir dit oui à la france
les habitants de la petite île ont voté
par référendum pour choisir leurs
statuts c'est-à-dire départements ou
territoires d'outre-mer notre envoyé
spécial bruno masure a suivi pour d'où
ce référendum dans le transall de
l'armée de l'air se pose sur la
minuscule piste daoudi on a un peu
l'impression de revenir cinq cents ans
en arrière
mayotte qui deviendra peut-être un jour
le centième départements français on
sera peut-être le plus beau mais il sans
conteste le plus pauvre
une grande partie des quarante mille
mahorais vivent dans la pauvreté pour ne
pas dire la misère mais apparemment tout
au moins heureux complètement ignorants
des pollutions de la vie moderne
ici pas de fumée du sinn pas
d'embouteillage ni de jukebox mais
pratiquement pas d'électricité ni d'eau
courante et encore surtout la lèpre ou
bien le choléra si cette île de 250
kilomètres carrés où 90% de la
population est analphabète musulmane est
polygame 6 at il tient tant à rester
française c'est surtout parce qu'elle
compte sur la france pour la défendre
des visées impérialistes des frères amis
comoriens
les élus voulaient la
départementalisation immédiate paris a
préféré proposer un statut spécial
pendant cinq ans d'ici là on espère
arriver à recoller les morceaux avec les
comoriens et surtout mettre mayotte sur
sa rampe de lancement économique tout en
effet tout reste à faire dans ce pays
qui importe presque tous y compris sa
nourriture aux grands profite d'ailleurs
de quelques-uns en attendant
emmaillotent la sauvage se met peu à peu
à l'heure de la métropole première
conséquence du oui franc et massif à la
france
les jeunes mahorais feront désormais
comme tous les français un passage de 12
mois à la caserne